>>> TOMORROW HOUSE REPUBLICANS
FACE A BIG, NEW HURDLE RIGHT ON
THE HEELS OF THEIR BRUISING
FIGHT OVER THE SPEAKERSHIP.
THEY NOW HAVE TO VOTE ON THE
RULES PACKAGE THAT WILL SET THE
PARAMETERS FOR HOW THIS CONGRESS
WILL FUNCTION OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS.
IF THE CHAOS OF LAST WEEK'S
ROUND 15 FIASCO IS ANY
INDICATION MONDAY'S VOTE WON'T
BE A CAKEWALK EITHER.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE IS
CNN'S SENIOR POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR SCOTT JENNINGS.
HI, SCOTT.
YOU WATCHED THIS PLAY OUT.
IT WAS THE LONGEST, MOST
COMBATIVE SPEAKER'S BATTLE IN
MORE THAN 160 YEARS.
BUT STEVE SCALISE THE NEW
MAJORITY LEADER IS ONE OF MANY
REPUBLICANS NOW PUTTING AN
OPTIMISTIC SPIN ON IT.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> AT SOME POINT THERE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO BE A CONFRONTATION
ABOUT CHANGING THE WAY THAT
WASHINGTON WORKS.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF US AS
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN
FRUSTRATED WITH THAT.
THIS GAME HAS GOT TO END.
THOSE WERE THE DISCUSSIONS WE'VE
HAD.
I THINK THAT IS HEALTHY BY THE
WAY THAT WE TOOK A FEW DAYS TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN SET UP A
CONGRESS THAT WORKS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> DO YOU THINK THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICAN PEOPLE VIEW WHAT
HAPPENED OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS
AS POLITICALLY HEALTHY?
>> OH, I THINK SOME OF THE
CONSERVATIVES DO, CERTAINLY.
I'M SURE DEMOCRATS THINK IT IS A
SIGN OF DYSFUNCTION.
I THINK A LOT OF AMERICANS IN
THE MIDDLE WERE PROBABLY
WATCHING IT ALL WITH SOME AMOUNT
OF AMUSEMENT BUT ARE WAITING TO
SEE WHETHER THE REPUBLICANS CAN
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE THINGS THEY
RAN ON -- INFLATION, BORDER, AND
SO FORTH.
TO ME, THAT IS THE REAL QUESTION
HERE IS NOT THE, WHAT IT TOOK TO
GET McCARTHY INTO THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE BUT NOW THAT HE HAS IT,
HOW DO THE RULES WORK?
WHAT IS THE FLOOR GOING TO LOOK
LIKE OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS?
>> RIGHT.
BUT I MEAN YOU CAN LEARN A LOT
FROM WATCHING THAT FIGHT BREAK
OUT AND HOW THE HARDLINERS MIGHT
BE MOVING FORWARD.
RIGHT?
YOU KNOW, DID THIS EXPERIENCE
TEACH THE HARDLINERS TO GOVERN
WITH THEIR PARTY OR TEACH THEM
TO FIGHT UNTIL THEY GET THEIR
WAY?
RIGHT?
>> OH, THEY CERTAINLY LEARNED A
LOT ABOUT THE WORD LEVERAGE IN
THIS FIGHT, I GUESS.
I GUESS WE'LL FIND OUT WHEN THE
RULES PACKAGE COMES OUT WHAT IT
REALLY LOOKS LIKE.
BUT I THINK WE WERE ALWAYS IN
FOR A VERY CLOSELY DIVIDED
CONGRESS.
THERE'S ONLY 222 REPUBLICANS.
THEN OF COURSE WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHICH WAS ON
FULL DISPLAY LAST WEEK THERE ARE
BETWEEN 6 AND 20 THAT AT ANY
GIVEN TIME ARE WILLING TO TAKE
MATTERS INTO THEIR OWN HANDS AND
BUCK LEADERSHIP.
I DO THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE
A LOT OF TUMULT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN CONGRESS FOR
INSTANCE WHO ARE NOT GOING TO
WANT TO CUT DEFENSE SPENDING
AMONG REPUBLICANS AND THERE ARE
REPUBLICANS WHO WANT TO DO THAT.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A DEBATE FOR
INSTANCE.
I THINK WE ARE IN FOR A LITTLE
MORE MUST SEE TV ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR.
WE SHOULD EXPECT THAT REALLY FOR
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
>> MINORITY LEADER HAKEEM
JEFFRIES IS OFFERING McCARTHY A
SPOT IN THE POLITICAL LIFE BOAT
TODAY.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> WE LOOK FORWARD TO TRYING TO
FIND SOME REASONABLE REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE WILLING TO BREAK FROM
THE EXTREME ELEMENT OF THEIR
CONFERENCE TO DO THE BUSINESS OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> DO YOU THINK McCARTHY WILL
TRY TO WORK WITH MODERATE
DEMOCRATS?
>> NO.
I DON'T.
I DON'T THINK HE NEEDS TO AT THE
MOMENT.
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO IS TRY TO
DRIVE AS MUCH COHESIVENESS AMONG
HIS OWN CONFERENCE.
WE'LL SEE HOW LONG THAT LASTS.
THERE ARE DEBATES TO COME,
HOWEVER, THAT LEND ONE TO
BELIEVE THERE MAY HAVE TO BE
BIPARTISAN WORK DONE TO DO THE
BUSINESS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHEN THE DEBT LIMIT COMES UP IN
THE SUMMER FOR INSTANCE YOU CAN
IMAGINE A WORLD WHERE THAT HAS
TO HAPPEN FOR THE DEBT LIMIT TO
BE RAISED.
IN THE SHORT TERM, WHAT HE HAS
TO DO IS GET EVERYBODY BELIEVING
THEY'RE ON THE SAME TEAM.
THAT IS ONE THING ABOUT LAST
WEEK THAT TROUBLED ME WAS THAT
THERE ARE A FEW PEOPLE THAT I
DON'T THINK NECESSARILY BELIEVE
THEY'RE ON THE SAME TEAM AS THE
OTHER 200 OR 215 PEOPLE.
THAT IS TROUBLING IF YOU HAVE
FOLKS OUT THERE WHO CARE MORE
ABOUT THEMSELVES THAN THE TEAM.
TO ME THAT IS KEVIN McCARTHY'S
FIRST TASK IS DRIVE A TEAM
MENTALITY AMONG 222
>> I HAVE TO ASK YOU, THERE HAS
BEEN A LOT OF CRITICISM FROM
REPUBLICANS OF BIDEN NOT
VISITING THE BORDER.
NOW HE HAS GONE THERE BUT DOES
IT CHANGE ANYTHING REALLY?
DID IT MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE?
THIS IS WHAT REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN CALLING FOR.
>> LONG OVERDUE TRIP IN MY
OPINION.
MAYBE HE'LL SEE NOW WHAT OTHER
AMERICANS SEE ON CNN AND OUR
NEWS EVERY NIGHT WHICH IS CHAOS
AT THE BORDER.
MAYBE, JUST MAYBE YOU'LL SEE
BOTH PARTIES WORK TOGETHER.
THIS IS THAT LONG, VEXING
PROBLEM, IMMIGRATION, BUT TRULY
IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AS WELL
AS A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A PROBLEM THIS BIG
YOU'D LIKE TO THINK THE
PRESIDENT OF ONE PARTY AND THE
CONGRESS OF ANOTHER PARTY COULD
GET TOGETHER AND DO SOMETHING.
MAYBE THAT WILL BE THE START OF
IT.
HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL AND THE
GLASS IS HALF FULL IS